thanks for having me guys but I really
appreciate you being organizing an
awesome event like this i really know
how much time and effort it takes and
really good job um just before we start
I'd like to ask is someone here in the
audience playing buzzword bingo at the
moment or during the conference I think
it's always a very funny game to play
but sometimes is also a little bit on
the expense of people spending a long
amount and lots of thoughts in coming up
some great terms for some complex idea
and especially there is one term that is
very often to find in this field and
that is actually one term I particularly
don't like which is a big data so what
is actually big data is is big data
about the size is a big data about
gigabytes terabytes petabytes whatever
what does the term 'big actually refer
to does it mean great data or as much
data as we can accumulate or something
like that so actually what I was looking
for is for a slightly more more useful
term and I'd like to talk about sensible
data so sensible data for me is
something that has actual is not just
data but it is actual information and so
useful information and this was just
something like a an idea I had for this
talk and I'm talking a little bit about
dealing with sensible data or and
with data in a sense of their way so
please be over for me well by the way my
name is needs I'm a freelance journalist
and consultant I do all things cloud
containers and configuration management
and stuff like that so if you actually
do play a buzzword bingo you're probably
on a very close match already I work a
lot as a data engineer for from
operations perspective I'm kind of a
believer in the Church of DevOps or
working together ops people and
developers is something i firmly believe
in and i'm also i have to admit an
occasional python user and developer i
have to admit that i was raised with
pearl is it do I have to go no I hope
not okay um I from time to time I do
some work for four grade I oh I work as
a developer evangelist there and what we
do there is dealing with data so as I
explained on the last slide I I used to
work a lot as a data engineer for
different projects from different
perspectives and that involved being
exposed to lots of different types of
data so is that on the left hand side
actually small data because you just use
a commands that have been around for
three or four decades so and is
something like Hadoop and the whole
ecosystem MapReduce and all the products
that are in this ecosystem is this just
a big data and does it actually fit for
every need when you have to process a
data in a well constructive way so
actually
I was missing something in the middle so
something that gets the job done like on
the left hand side but this probably is
lightly more usable but does not come
with the complexity on the right hand
side we are dealing with exploring data
today and I was kind of looking for
something that is able to deal with
several 100 gigabytes to some terabyte
that is actually able to answer within a
subset and a round trip time and which
is foremost easy to set up maintain and
which is also able to deal with
increasing data so that something like
this might be did you figure it out it
is a kind of a topless of the most
popular the most popular web web
browsers that access some web server and
well this is analytics zero dot one or
something like that um but this is
probably not a very sustainable so I was
looking for somewhere something more
sustainable but not as complex as the
big guys so if it comes to dealing with
data well classical databases easily
come to mind something like my sequel
postgresql so I come from an open source
environment but if you don't care maybe
even some stuff from Microsoft where
from Oracle but those a product are
pretty difficult if they go beyond a
certain point a certain point where they
reach the limit of vertical scaling so
at some point there is
no bigger computer available or at least
not for reasonable price and if you come
to this point it becomes difficult
because there are options to cluster a
classic sequel database but it actually
requires an expert if it's just adding
some read slaves that's probably okay
you'll find lots and lots of recipes of
doing that in the internet but if it
comes to the more complex stuff to scale
out something like that in a reliable
way and a scalable way that can be done
but it's hard to do so and then there's
all this or the no sequel environment
and scaling out is usually slightly more
easy in this field but still it's very
hard to actually pick one of those
databases no sequel databases each comes
with their own dialect and an API and
their own query language and their own
concept and they work or in a different
way and if one actually fits for one
specific problem it is not guarantee
that it also fits for other problems as
well and because actually that's what we
invented back in nineteen seventy five
is equal to have a kind of uniform way
to access data well and we talked about
a Hadoop and the whole real big data
environments already it's okay if you
have actual
a project that fit into as an
environment like this but if it just
comes to determining what are the most
popular web browsers for your web server
it probably doesn't make sense to hire a
whole IT team maintaining your Hadoop
environment and buying a whole hardware
cluster for that so what I'd like to do
right now in the rather beginning is
doing a short demo well and I'd like
actually to install configure and launch
a database and not only a database a
cluster database a classic database
consisting of several nodes I'd like to
enable replication charting partitioning
and I'd also like to add some features
for the the ops Forks as well installing
a web-based admin UI and enable
monitoring so if you try to do that in a
classical say our dbms I guess a skilled
team is at least well what would you say
some days maybe we occupied with it and
I have prepared a short demo let me see
I'm using docker containers for that are
you all familiar with docker containers
who has no idea how to start the docker
container could you please raise your
hand okay okay then I explained that is
that's not a problem can you read that
right them I started docker container
with a docker run command and actually I
can just start the create container the
create container is a packaged
a version of the open source project
itself and that is hosted at dhaka at
the docker hub and if it is it's already
on my computer but actually on this
computer is nothing installed but dhaka
itself and it just caches at the first
time i launched this and I practice the
demo2 hours ago so we don't need to wait
for the download so now i start the
container get some debugging output
which is kind of not necessary for us
and with the skilled i I find it's not
really necessary but I see there's a
link in here because the docker
container has a private network attached
to it and on this private network the
software launches on board 4200 and I
just open a browser to that address did
this work probably a little bit more
yeah and this is just it looks very
similar to several no sequel databases
as well but there's an admin link as
well and ok I started a cluster before
let me just shut down the cluster again
so we see actually all stuff
let me stop that
I have a short script to take care of
removing everything let's see okay now I
have a fresh docker with no images and
no containers running I just repeat the
last command we once again see the boot
up messages and well actually usually I
directly discard them but it's very
convenient to open link here and to add
the admin URL yeah so what we see here
is kind of the the monitoring we have a
one node cluster at the moment you can
see it on on on the top can you actually
read that let me see if I can make this
a little bit larger I have a one node
cluster this is the version this is the
cluster name and this is the class the
load at the moment there's nothing in my
cluster okay but I promised to launch a
five node cluster so I go back to the to
my hold on a second
you
so as you remember this is the same
command I just ran before minus D means
as a demon once again my password and I
started the whole thing again second
time third time and the fourth tile in
the fifth time and then let's go back to
the admin UI and as you can see right
now at the moment we have pre and now we
have even a five nodes at the moment so
all this results in a short peak in the
load but after a few seconds we are back
to normal again and actually that's it
so we now have a full cluster of
database nodes running on all on the
same machine which actually makes no
real sense in a production environment
but it works as you can see right now
there are some some warning on the right
hand side I should have unconsidered it
exploited complaints about that I did
not tell the cluster beforehand how many
notes I actually planned to spin up
because we obviously in a disputed
system have to come up with some means
of battling against the split brain has
lit brain problem and it just complains
over there but this is just a single
cycle kumon I could type if I my hand my
hands weren't tied to this microphone
yeah and that's it and it's up and
running I get some information well I
can look here for for the cluster on the
there is a tap for each single node you
can see the load in
there and the disk usage and so on which
is at this point or the same for all
five nodes you see the version you can
even do a certain degree mix up the
version so just by adding new nodes to
the database means that you can add and
also remove a nodes to your cluster at
the moment let me see here it's tables
we have nothing in our database but as
soon as we populate them you can
distribute the database over the whole
cluster and that completely happens
automatically I have prepared a short
example in a few seconds in a few
minutes there's something else to show
at this point I don't think so let me go
back to the presentation
Oh
next time I don't use the better version
of ubuntu okay well a few words about
well all the features of great I don't
need to read them all the main feature
is probably it's a distributed sequel
database so you actually talk sequel to
create no fancy a rest dialect or
something like that it has all the
features I I mentioned already auto
sharing partitioning replication I can
show you in a minute well how easy it is
to and so I just demo to you and you can
do real-time search aggregations and
this is probably something this needs
some expression as since created she
uses all the distributed nodes or for
those aggregations so it does not use
the nodes just for fetching the data so
as much aggregation as it's possible is
done on the distributed nodes which is a
major feature as well well this is all
the components I don't think we need to
go to more detail right here create
implements a masa less shared nothing
architecture what does this mean and
what does this mean especially in a
container I'll context that means that
all nodes are actually the same and
there is no specific master in terms of
some single point of system you need to
contact so if you have a container
environment as I showed here I have here
a free container house and want to free
a nine total application containers
and you could for example launch create
a container on each of the hose and you
obviously have to make sure that they
get connected by each other and so each
application container can save its state
into the local great instance which is
interconnected with all other create
instances so that you have kind of well
an omnipresent persistent layer laggin
data either that spends your whole
container infrastructure this comes
really in handy if you want to deal with
the problem of persisting state in
application environments where an
application container should be
ephemeral and could be discarded at any
time so creators an open source project
and has several components the blue
components are written by create itself
and the create community and there are
some some core parts depend on
elasticsearch which is actually a basic
foundation of create but as you can see
create is not just that layer on top of
elasticsearch it adds some substantial
features as well as you can see on the
graphic and we have also some some other
open source projects for example the
presto sequel plaza the neti component
and is obviously lucene which
elasticsearch depends on likewise I
prepared some some demo code well there
drivers available for create four
different programming languages and if
it comes to a simple connecting to a
database to a secure database this is no
real magic but still I wanted to
highlight a few things here so we have
this a driver which is in repositories
that's easy to install I also use here
the the faker factory to create some
random data so for example the fake last
name you can create good looking last
names for different locales and stuff
like that you can also create social
security numbers and addresses and URLs
and whatever it's a it's a very
interesting project so if you want to
populate a database in a useful way have
a look at faker so what we do is we
connect to our cluster we execute we
create a schema and then we just add a
number of records to the database so
well I can actually show you that but
there's no not much to see let me see
I probably have to adapt a I am let me
see
okay well that's even a more easier um
we have this play cluster so everyone
can play with in the internet play grade
I oh and that's publicly available
please be kind and considerable of your
co sandbox players every now and then we
restart this cluster and I use it at the
moment and so I just and oh and is no
more so as available are probably my
network connection is not let me change
that to the local system
so i just added a sixth note to the
container which is because of the minus
p flag at dhaka exposes its its ports to
the host machine as well so i can
address it at localhost and now my
script well this is a bet d Moloch also
if you're actually interested in looking
at that I can show you later on actually
it does not do much magic but there are
three things I'd like to point out if
you look closely I created a table if it
does not exist just with the reference
integer and I inserted quite different
columns in there so we have a dynamic
schema in ink raid which can also be
turned off but if you add new fields on
the fly you can do that at any time and
without any performance penalty it comes
in handy especially if you have evolving
and changing data definitions like with
adding a new field in your time series
date or something like that and there's
something else I made this connection
with a client connect core and in my
demo code there was just a single line
but as we've seen we now have a cluster
of six machines and since we have a
shared nothing architecture we can
contact any of those six nodes at the
moment and it doesn't make any
difference which one because the nodes
themselves determine where does the
actual data go to which actual note
the data go and roots the data they're
automatically that is completely
transparent for for the user so if you
actually and you can do this in all
Klein's and also on a command-line
client and so on you can have a list of
several nodes and the client just picks
one and if one is not available it picks
the next one and so on it implements a
round-robin schema on that so that adds
both high availability as well as load
balancing if you have several
connections going to the cluster at the
same time very important especially for
people who actually use grade is
inserting vast amounts of data and doing
so can be obviously done in in a few
different ways the most simple one is
obviously connecting to the database
setting up an insert statement and
executing this statement but obviously
this is slower compared to doing actual
bulk insert as I did here on the on the
lower part of the demo where you prepare
your payload first and then do and
execute many but the placeholders and
then a whole payload so usually we do
some benchmarking we do something like
1,000 or 10,000 inserts in a single bug
statement and this speeds up everything
very much you can also feed create
directly with with Jason so if you have
already a JSON data you can feed it also
directly over the rest api and if you
have different file formats
we have added a new feature that you can
write specific plugins that parses that
data directly and the client itself is
not at all involved in dealing with the
data so the server itself fetches the
data say from its restore or from HDFS
or from some other data stores if you
have vast amounts of data for that well
there are some caveats especially about
retrieving you probably know the cap
theorem consistency availability and
partition tolerance are free major
properties of distributed systems and
unfortunately you usually can only take
two of them and you have to deal with
some limitations on the third and for
example create implements eventual
consistency which means the database is
a consistent but it is not guaranteed at
at which time so it in production it
just takes a few seconds and after that
you have the same stay the same
consistent stayed on all nodes that is
well the consequence of the cap theorem
we have also once you read data after
you you have rode it you have also
consistency and a guarantee that once
the data is once read it is consistent
in subsequent queries so if you actually
need high performance it's very
important to to have a very well-thought
data architecture because that
dramatically affect the
or query performance but if you do so
you can achieve astonishing performance
values you should avoid complex joint
and especially transactions transactions
are not implemented on a sequel level
but need to be implemented on on the
logic of the application itself if you
really need them but in most situations
it is not really necessary I don't know
if you know this paper from I think it
was someone from from Amazon who came up
with this term of the eventual
consistency deserve very interesting a
paper to read yeah and well something
great is a good match is when you
actually combine it with data exploring
and visualization tools and the project
just recently added a couple of new
tools and there and I think they will
get released soon so that you can
actually do some graphical browser based
exploring and drawing cool pie charts
and stuff like that well some final
notes on performance they actually users
that use create in a production
environment they run up to 1100 nodes in
a cluster we actually set up a cluster
with virtualization and in containers
with about 1000 nodes if you really plan
to do something like that contact
contact us so that we can support you
because we found out that container
virtualization is still something
complex to deal with
especially at those scales but it worked
so some people actually storm trillions
of document blobs they are they insert
more than 3 billions a day or well our
high school was at the moment in
searching for dot 5 million records
lines per second in a cluster and that
was not even a 1000 node cluster but I
think a couple of 120 or something yeah
and this is just a summary of probably
everything I told you so for developers
is nice that you can use a sequel force
during your data in a database Python
drivers are available there our server
or ms available also for other
programming languages it's easy to
integrate with existing solutions with
some sensible thought about is you can
also use some other features I did not
mention so far from the no sequel world
as well chima schema changes and so on
and so on and obviously it's also very
useful for admins and operations folks
like me there are several forms of
installation so thank you very much
another news one more comment no I just
wanted to ask there are some questions I
detective yes we have well only two
minutes left I'm sorry okay is there any
question in the back yes hi thank you
for that walk I have two questions first
one would be would you consider great
more and oltp or all up database and
second one did you run any benchmark
because they are standard benchmark like
the TPC wants g bch for example and it
would be interesting to see results of
that I start with the the second one we
actually do frequently benchmarks but as
we all know benchmarks are the different
a difficult topic but have a look at our
blop to our block where we just recently
published a few numbers but this is an
ongoing process and we add more and more
stuff in there so if you are interested
in some specific scenarios reach out to
us and we always try to reproduce that
what was your your first question I'm
not sure if I gather that oh I'm sorry
would you consider it more like an OLTP
so like transaction based database or
all up so more for analytics stuff well
it depends actually on your use case we
have very different use cases as I
explained there is no consistency
guarantee all the time
so it's mostly useful if you have some
streaming data that you actually write
into the database and then you can do
analytics on top of that that works very
well and especially works with awesome
response times but it depends on the
level of consistency you actually
require any more anyone else know any
more questions oh ok ok it's coming oh
thanks for the talk she's a small
questions do you think this is
production ready or something in
development would you recommend it for a
production system which level you think
you are of maturity for sure no well as
seriously they are companies using this
in a production environment at the
moment so for example there's a company
who has vast amounts of logging data I
think they providing a security service
for their clients and they're collecting
I think the numbers have been from them
at least the first 14 billion records on
a day that's I think a 2 of 3 digit a
gigabyte number and they do extensive
analytics on top of that and they use
this in production and over there
thank you for the talk just a quick
question about how you invention that
the crew performs is heavily impacted by
the data schema do you provide some
guidelines how to turn a dieter
non-normalized schema into some
denominator which will perform great on
your database yeah there is no general
answer to the actual question but we
have a lot of use cases we describe and
on the web page on the block and if your
use case is not in there let us know and
we always are very interested where just
the we started two and a half years ago
and so we are very interested to find
out what others are interested in and
but with some tweaking we so far have
solved every challenge so far I think
that was almost the last question the
very last one is over there and then we
go to coffee break hi thanks for to talk
for a while you weren't supporting join
syntax and join queries I think you
introduced that recently can you share
any benchmark information or data on
that because elasticsearch only has
parent-child relationship so I was
wondering how you guys solve this and
and other any results you can share so
it depends on the on the type of the
joints that you actually perform not all
are supported and I have to relay you to
the extra developers because I don't
know about all the details of all
specific John types out of my head
I think we did not do extensive
benchmarking on that but that is on the
backlog and we certainly should do that
the thing is some of the joints are
cheap and some are expensive and the
expensive ones will either we be will
ever remain expensive and one could
argue if you really need them if then
this is the right solution or if this is
the right approach to use a distributed
system like that but very small changes
in the query can dramatically affect the
overall performance and sometimes it
just takes some the anomalies a shin or
something and a simple tweak like this
and if you add some extra knowledge to
your data schema you can speed up
dramatically okay if you have something
once again I say that was really
suggestion let's continue the discussion
then in the coffee break yeah thank you
very much Niels all right